Now it's your turn.
Let's move on to another more real-world example.
Now, this right here is a groundbreaking new application called Udacity Retain.
Aside from a snazzy name, it,
it does have some pretty good organization when you look at the underlying code.
So let's do just that.
We have an HTML file, a CSS file, and a JavaScript file.
If you look at the JavaScript file, we see a pretty similar organization in
this app as we saw in our pizza application.
Now, we just spent some time going over the pizza application together
just a moment ago.
So, go ahead and clone this repo and get it onto your local machine.
Then take a look at it and try to figure out roughly how it's organized.
You will see some similarities between the pizza app and this app here.
Now, if you have a moment of disorientation, that's normal.
Anytime I look at someone else's code for
the first time, it takes me a bit to get my bearings.
[SOUND] So
don't worry if it takes you a few minutes to start understanding things.
Feel free to comment things out and see what breaks.
Add comments as you figure out what things do and notice the big picture.
Does the model ever talk to the view directly?
How about the view to the model?